a Former Intelligence official turned
whistleblower has given Congress and the
intelligence Community Inspector General
extensive classified information that
deeply covered programs that he says
possess retrieved intact and partially
intact craft of non-human origin he goes
on and explains why he's convinced this
is ET says analysis is determined that
the objects retrieved are of exotic
origin non-human intelligence whether
extraterrestrial or An Origin based on
the vehicle morphologies the material
science Testing and the possession of
unique Atomic arrangements and
radiological signatures okay
nah no that's not real if there is
anything that kind of resembles aliens
in the world and this is a hard pill to
swallow and they're demons okay they're
demons demons aliens almost certainly do
not exist there's zero evidence
whatsoever for aliens existing